[Music]
we are not baby people not baby people
not at all and it's not that there's
anything wrong with that if that's your
life choice if I mean what's not to like
about a baby
except for everything that's what I say
we don't feel the need to glorify our
own ego by creating ourselves yeah yeah
we don't need to see ourselves in the
world
we're Dinks we are doing ya double
income no kids but actually no I heard a
new one but dildos weirdo dildos weird
dildos double income large dog owner oh
we're enough for each other we're two
adults in love in love very much in love
we can look at each other and we don't
even have to say anything to each other
for hours of course yeah people need
distraction that's why you have a baby
isn't it is because you've run out of
things to say to each other those
couples don't like each other I really
don't think we're doing and they need to
put something in between themselves so
they can have you know it's like oh you
can't be in a room alone I really do
believe that the way that people love oh
baby they're babies so there's no wheat
there's no gluten there's no sugar
organic band-aids no plastic baby seat
when you get in the car
god forbid gummy vitamins come on
just swallow a vitamin oh and also
babies tear you in half you my body is
not a baby factory no always say that
has a lot of other purposes I've been
doing kegels since I was 10 years old
she has been doing kegels since 10:00
humans weren't meant to have kids it's
not natural when people have babies
they're suddenly just clown people you
know we're not clowns and I like to talk
about things outside of who pooped when
and for how long they poop right you
know we're mature adults we're adults
okay we're not baby people
we're adult people we're
very mature adults yeah
[Music]